die vor uns liegende bundestagswahl ist
eine zäsur personell denn es endet die
16-jährige ihrer merkel aber ganz sicher
auch wirtschafts und
gesellschaftspolitischen in deutschland
steht vor einem gigantischen
transformationsprozess der wirtschaft
und das in zeiten da die pandemie noch
längst nicht überwunden ist und ihre
ökonomischen folgen noch nicht absehbar
sind wie gelingt der sozialverträglich
ökologisch notwendige umbau unserer
wirtschaft
wir gestalten wie eine gerechte
gesellschaft in der nach kona er mit
diesen fragen begrüße ich sie sehr
herzlich bei unter den linden
und ich freue mich sehr über meine gäste
zum einen begrüße ich den präsidenten
der bundesvereinigung der deutschen
arbeitgeberverbände rainer dulger die
sie vertreten die wirtschaftspolitischen
interessen von rund einer millionen
unternehmen mit rund 20 millionen
arbeitnehmern herzlich willkommen und
ich begrüße sehr herzlich rainer
hoffmann den vorsitzenden des deutschen
gewerkschaftsbundes sie vertreten die
interessen von rund sechs millionen
mitgliedern also sie sprechen beide für
viele
heute hier am tisch haben kommenden
sonntag ist die bundestagswahl und
damit endet ein bundestagswahlkampf der
polarisierte war als man das von den
letzten wahlkämpfen kennt woran liegt
das was ist aus ihrer sicht anders ich
glaube der große unterschied zu den
bisherigen wahlkämpfen die wir in den
letzten längst in den letzten zwei drei
perioden erleben durften ist dass angela
merkel aufhört und ist ja hier wirklich
raum entsteht für einen echten neuanfang
und das ist auch genau das was wir uns
in der wirtschaft wünschen es geht ums
große ganze dieses land braucht dringend
reformen wir brauchen dringend einen
nachfolger von angela merkel der
reformwille mitbringt und auch
umsetzungsfähigkeit mitbringen auch den
willen umsetzen dieses land weiterhin
voran zu bringen und das ist das was
diese wahl so besonders macht
viele sprechen auch von einer
richtungswahl herr hoffmann die einen
sagen
dass wir waren vor einem linksruck die
anderen waren vor einem weiter so
liegt das daran dass die ära merkel nach
16 jahren zu ende oder hat das noch
andere gründe nein ich fühle mich dem
anschließen dass der bürger gesagt hat
natürlich ist das eine bundestagswahl
mit einer zäsur wo frau dr merkel nicht
mehr antritt aber wir haben auch enorme
herausforderungen weit über die
bewältigung der pandemie hinaus den
strukturwandel der deutschland erreicht
hat der europa erreicht hat ist wirklich
anspruchsvoll so dass es hier wirklich
darauf ankommt gelingt ist dass wir in
der nächsten dekade in den 20er jahren
wirklich die voraussetzungen dafür
schaffen dass dieses land
wettbewerbsfähig bleibt dass dieses land
ökonomisch stark aber auch sozial
gerecht bleibt darauf kommt es an und
daran messen wie der deutsche
gewerkschaftsbund alle demokratischen
parteien würden sie auch sagen ist es
doch ein stück weit auch in angst
wahlkampf denn wenn die rote socken
kampagne wieder ausgepackt wird dir nun
94 war lange her es ist ja doch anders
als andere wahl könnte angst dass kein
guter berater und ich glaube ich
verfängt diese kampagne auch nicht ich
halte es nicht für relativ hilflos wie
sieht man das dann in der wirtschaft ich
denke mal
ängste gibt es auf allen seiten vor
vielen dingen aber sollten nach vorne
blicken und uns über überlegen was
braucht dieses land und da haben wir
wirtschaftsvertreter klare perspektiven
wir erwarten von einer neuen
bundesregierung dass reformen
entschlossen angegangen werden wir
brauchen eine deckelung der sozialkosten
wir sind ja darauf hingewiesen worden
wir sind mit der nase rein gestoßen
worden in dieser pandemie dass wir in
der digitalisierung nicht schnell genug
vorankommen dass wir in unseren schulen
einiges an nachholbedarf haben dass wir
auch in unserer arbeitswelt den nächsten
schritt nach vorne machen und dieses new
work was wir jetzt in der pandemie
erleben durften mit viel home office
weiter muss auch nur reality werden wir
haben fragen zu beantworten führt für
die gesamte dekarbonisierung die vor uns
liegt wir haben enorme technologiewandel
in unserer industrie vor uns und das
alles den aufgaben der braucht
entschlossenheit
er braucht vor allem auch in roten
hatten und diesen roten faden nicht aus
den augen verlieren die nächsten vier
jahre werden gar nicht reichen wir
werden zwei legislaturen brauchen um das
in den griff zu bekommen wir werden
enorme investitionen zu brauchen und
deswegen ist es umso wichtiger dass wir
eine regierung bekommen die ein klare
richtung mitbringt einen klaren roten
faden erkennen lässt wie wir dieses land
durch diese enormen herausforderungen
und steuern und wie wir unseren
wohlstand behalten und damit auch unsere
soziale absicherung und damit auch
unsere soziale gerechtigkeit ich glaube
das ist ein weg der entscheiden zeit
wird und deswegen geht es in dieser wahl
um so viel es geht auch so viel weil wir
eine sehr ungewöhnliche zeit hinter uns
haben mit der pandemie die uns
anderthalb jahre fast zwei jahre
intensiv beschäftigt hat die wirtschaft
auch entsprechend getroffen hat würden
sie sagen dass diese pandemie die
unterschiedlichen gruppen unserer
gesellschaft auch sehr unterschiedlich
getroffen
ich würde vielleicht noch einen schritt
weiter nach vorne gehen die pandemie kam
noch oben drauf ich möchte daran
erinnern dass 2009 10 bereits im
rezessionsjahr war in dem maschinenbau
und automobil land deutschland hat man
gemerkt es kommen veränderungen auf uns
zu die dekarbonisierung ist in aller
munde die elektrifizierung der fahrzeuge
das ist eine enorme umstellung in all
dem wovon wir bisher wirtschaftlich
gelebt haben und uns das was unseren
wohlstand begründet hat und da oben
drauf kam dann noch die pandemie also
das ist noch um ein mehrfaches verstärkt
worden und das hat uns bei vielen dingen
die augen geöffnet 1 2 habe ich eben
schon genannt was unsere schulische
bildung angeht was unser
gesundheitssystem angehen aber es zeigt
uns auch deutschland muss wieder
einfacher werden deutschland muss wieder
schneller werden wir brauchen um diese
enormen herausforderungen zu bewältigen
schnellere verwaltungsabläufe wir
brauchen einfach ein deutschland das
wieder befreit ist wir brauchen wieder
den geist von ludwig erhaltung all das
in den griff zu bekommen aber würden sie
sagen dass es die unterschiedlichen
gruppen auch unterschiedlich hart
getroffen
hat es natürlich mehr wenn wir jetzt mal
über schon allein über die ganzen
branchen gehen von der industrie
handwerk dienstleistung
hotellerie gastronomie da sehen sie
natürlich schon ein riesen unterschied
gewinnt natürlich enorm getroffen hat
wie hotellerie und gastronomie da sind
aber auch gute hilfen geflossen da ist
viel getan worden man konnte jetzt nicht
alles leid lindern aber es ist trotzdem
viel geschehen durch die kurzarbeit und
das kurzarbeitergeld ist auch in der
industrie im handwerk überall bei den
gewerbetreibenden vieles abgefangen
worden aber wir merken auch dass wir
nicht genügend pflegepersonal haben wir
hatten auch eine überlastung der
krankenhäuser und die impfkampagnen sind
auch nur am anfang schleppend angelaufen
alters hat uns glaube ich gezeigt wie
man auf englisch sagen würde der
informant hören wo wir noch anpacken
müssen und was mir in zukunft alles
besser machen können sie sagen dass sie
keine das soziale gefälle in unserer
gesellschaft aufzeigt oder aber
vielleicht noch stärker er sagt wie ein
brennglas das so die häufig noch
berichtet wo die
sozialen schwächen aufgedeckt wurden das
fängt im bildungssystem an aufgrund der
pandemie aufgrund von homeschooling sind
insbesondere kinder aus
einkommensschwachen familien wirklich
abgehängt wurden das ist ein richtig
großes problem
wir haben aber auch gesehen dass gerade
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer in
einkommensschwachen branchen in
besonderer weise von der panne betroffen
waren sie haben die größeren
einkommensverluste hinnehmen müssen und
wir dürfen die frauen nicht vergessen
die besonderes geleistet haben aber auch
hier von der pandemie in besonderer
weise getroffen worden und wir das
risiko haben das ist wieder ein zurück
zu tradierten rollenbildern gibt das
glaube ich ist ein risiko und da müssen
wir achtsam sein dass ich diese
verschärfung verfestigung von sozialer
ungleichheit auch zwischen den
geschlechtern nicht fest setzt sondern
da müssen wir durchaus mit einem
reformwillen und einem reform anspruch
die schwächen die wir in der pandemie
erlebt haben wirklich zum anlass nehmen
das soziale gerechtigkeit in diesem land
groß geschrieben wird
wenn man sich das anschaut in der
wirtschaft wie die wirtschaft so durch
die pandemie komme sie haben es ja
teilweise schon gesagt dass die branchen
sehr unterschiedlich da durchgekommen
sind einige haben
sehr davon profitiert andere hat es
ruiniert
haben die korona hilfen denn die
richtigen aufgaben mechanismen gebildet
war das richtig was da alles in die hand
genommen wurde und was angela leitwort
ich bin
zusammenfassend wo wir jetzt in der sag
mal endphase dieser pandemie stehen nach
wie vor der auffassung dass im großen
ganzes vieles gut gelaufen ist wenn wir
uns auch in anderen ländern dieser welt
umschauen haben wir vieles ganz gut
gemeistert es ist hinterher immer klar
dass man viele hätte dass vieles hätte
besser machen können schneller anders
aber im grossen ganzen sind wir was
nicht gut gelaufen was sag ich immer so
gut gelaufen das beste beispiel ist das
kurzarbeitergeld was wir deutsche
erfindung ist was mittlerweile viele
andere länder übernommen haben das hat
hervorragend geklappt muss aber dazu
sagen dass konnte auch nur so gut
klappen weil wir vorher haus gehalten
haben weil wir eine schuldenbremse
hatten weil die kassen voll waren und
weil auch einfach genügend geld dafür da
war aus acht bis neun fetten jahren und
das ist gut gelaufen wir haben keine
massenentlassungen gehabt und wir haben
vieles durch die
zahlungen dies an gastronomen hoteliers
und so weiter gab abfangen können
abfedern können aber schauen sie mal ins
handwerk
auf den baustellen ging es einigermaßen
nach einer holprigen anlaufzeit aber die
ganzen körper nahen dienstleistungen die
durften ja teilweise bis zu einem jahr
ihre berufe gar nicht mehr ausüben also
die hat es natürlich verheerend
getroffen die ganzen kleinen hotellerie
und gastronomie betriebe die vorher
schon auch zu kratzen hatten überhaupt
ich sage mal ihre existenz behaupten zu
können die hat alle wirklich schlimm
getroffen die ganzen schausteller also
das ganze thema volksfest das ist ja
vieles über jahre nicht bedient worden
kinos was kann da vieles aufzählen die
ist ganz einfach ganz hart getroffen hat
in der industrie ich selbst komme aus
der industrie aus der metall und
elektroindustrie in der industrie ging
es einigermaßen da gab es auch große
unterschiede aber im großen ganzen
konnte man durch das kurzarbeitergeld
und durch die mechanismen mit denen wir
schon in vorangegangenen krisen gelernt
hatten mit diesen instrumenten konnten
wir ja umgehen das ganz gut abfedern
aber das ganze thema wie eben genannt
handwerk körpernah dienstleistungen
hotellerie gastronomie die konnten ja
mit diesen instrumenten noch gar nicht
umgehen also thema kurzarbeit thema
einmal in so eine krise geraten ich
erinnere daran dass die lehman-krise die
letzte große die wir hatten da war ja
mit hotellerie und gastronomie alles in
ordnung das war eine finanzkrise und
jetzt trifft plötzlich auch diese
betriebe die auch in der regel nicht so
krisenfest aufgestellt sind wie das
industrieunternehmen ist also es hat
doch schäden gegeben es hat doch auch
viele einbußen gegeben und daraus können
wir nur lernen aber im grossen ganzen
ist vieles gut gelaufen
wenn man sich das aus sicht der
gewerkschaften anschaut einerseits gab
es das kurzarbeitergeld schon erwähnt
worden es gab direkthilfen für
unternehmen
alles um arbeitsplätze zu erhalten aber
wir haben gehört solo selbstständige zum
beispiel sind oft durchs raster gefallen
stück weit die sind aber meistens auch
gesellschaftlich gar nicht organisiert
würden sie sagen aus gesellschaft aus
gewerkschaftlicher sicht ist eigentlich
alles ganz gut gelaufen oder sehen sie
nachholbedarf defizite nein ich würde
mich ein bürger anschließend dass vieles
wirklich gut gelaufen ist auch auf
bewährte instrumente wie dem
kurzarbeitergeld zurückgegriffen werden
konnte was im übrigen in der regel
beitragsfinanzierte leistungen sind wo
jetzt die kassen der besen und deshalb
steuerzuschüsse notwendig sein werden
aber wir haben bestimmte personengruppen
selbstständige kulturschaffende die
nicht in den systemen der sozialen
sicherung integriert sind das sagt nicht
sprechen unser system der sozialen
sicherung wir brauchen eine
erwerbstätigenversicherung
beispielsweise auch für
kulturschaffende dass sie in solchen
krisensituationen wo arbeitslosigkeit
kurzarbeit droht auch abgefangen werden
da sind entsprechende hilfsmaßnahmen
getroffen worden das ist erstmal und
aber strukturell müssen wir jetzt daraus
lernen dass wir
gerade für diese personengruppen auch
die zugänge zu den systemen der sozialen
sicherung garantieren
sie haben eben schon gesagt es gab leute
die verloren haben während der pandemie
aber es gab natürlich auch eine ganze
reihe die gewonnen haben die zahl der
millionäre ist gestiegen das vermögen
der milliardäre ist gewachsen viele
kritisieren dass gerade auch jetzt im
wahlkampf wird das durchaus des öfteren
benannt drückt diese tatsache einen
fehler aus und schadet das letztendlich
dem image der unternehmer allgemein
das glaube ich weniger es gibt ja diese
armut studie die auch immer jedes jahr
neu vorgelegt wird die hat schon
deutlich gezeigt dass in deutschland auf
einem hohen niveau geklagt wird und dass
die schere bei weitem nicht so weit
auseinander gelaufen ist wie sie zum
beispiel in anderen europäischen ländern
während dieser krise auseinander
gelaufen ist die schere zwischen arm und
reich und was wir jetzt im moment
wirklich nicht tun sollten ist eine neid
debatte darüber führen ob es jetzt in
diesem land reichere und ärmere gibt
sondern wir sollten uns darauf
konzentrieren was uns erfolgreich
gemacht hat und eines ist klar nach
dieser krise wo wirklich viele
gewerbetreibende schwer angeschlagen
wurden wären steuererhöhungen oder auch
eine erhöhung von sozialabgaben das
falscheste was wir tun können wir müssen
genau jetzt die sozialabgaben bei 40
prozent deckeln wir müssen genau jetzt
darüber reden dass wir keine steuerung
erhöhungen weder für unternehmen noch
für gewerbetreibende gebrauchen können
weil jetzt erst mal wieder alle auf die
beine kommen müssen und diese
neiddebatte die jetzt teilweise auch im
wahlkampf geführt wird ist das
falscheste was dieses land jetzt
gebrauchen kann wir brauchen
aufbruchstimmung grünen sind nach vorne
sehen wir werden auch für all das was
vor uns liegt enorm viel geld brauchen
um diese investitionen überhaupt leisten
zu können
und deswegen ist es wichtig dass die
wirtschaft bringen muss wenn die
wirtschaft nicht läuft wird für alles
nicht genug geld da sein auch nicht für
die sozialleistungen des staates und
deswegen muss der fokus im moment gerade
nach dieser krise sehr darauf gelenkt
werden die wirtschaft muss laufen die
wirtschaft muss bremen sonst kommt
dieses land nicht richtig auf die beine
und das ist glaube ich das was wir in
den augen behalten sollen in eine
neiddebatte hilft da überhaupt nicht
weiter bei debatte ist das stichwort
woher kommt dieser neid
das sollten wir die fragen die die
debatte führen
geht es denn dabei auch so ein bisschen
um die wertschätzung von unternehmern
und wirtschaft
wenn sie manchmal wundert mich das sehr
weil die wertschätzung für die
unternehmen für die unternehmen aber
wenn sie in den betrieben sind wenn sie
mit den beschäftigten sprechen wenn sie
mit menschen sprechen die im ländlichen
raum leben wo es ein zwei größere
betriebe hat die wertschätzung ist da
aber diesen leuten die wissen dass diese
betriebe teil ihrer existenzgrundlage
sind die wissen dass diese betriebe teil
ihres sozialen wohlstandes auch sind der
sozialen sicherungssysteme weil dieses
geld um all diese systeme zu unterhalten
und diese sozialleistung zu erbringen in
diesen betrieben erwirtschaftet wird
also die wertschätzung ist glaube ich
schon da und deswegen ist es immer
schwierig herauszufinden wer genau jetzt
diese debatte befeuert und warum weil
ich glaube viele
wissen dass ohne eine florierende
wirtschaft auch alle sozialleistungen
über die wir hier sprechen nicht möglich
sind und deswegen sollten wir den blick
darauf richten dass die wirtschaft pumpt
der situation uns auch allen gut gehen
und dann wird es auch weiterhin
hochkarätige sozialleistungen geben kann
die wirtschaft muss bringen muss
angekurbelt werden jahrzehnte ist es ja
immer dass die politik sich aus der
wirtschaft eigentlich ausfällt oder
aushalten sollte jetzt durch die vielen
rettungsschirme und die vielen maßnahmen
die ergriffen worden es hat der staat
sich ja massiv eingemischt auch in die
in die wirtschaft muss
angesichts dieser milliarden und
billionen die dort geflossen sind ein
aussetzen der schwarzen null die folge
sein ich will zunächst einmal auf die
vermeintliche neiddebatte eingehen weil
ich diese einschätzung überhaupt nicht
teil es geht nicht um den neid debatte
sondern es geht wirklich um soziale
gerechtigkeit
und menschen in diesem lande haben
glaube ich schon ein sehr feines gespür
dafür ob es hier wirklich gerecht zugeht
oder nicht und da geht es nicht um neid
sondern es geht darum dass wir erleben
dass manche branchen beispielsweise die
logistikbranche der internethandel
milliardengewinne gemacht hat die zum
teil überhaupt nicht in deutschland
geschweige denn in europa bezahlt werden
also wir brauchen hier wirklich mehr
steuergerechtigkeit und das hat nichts
mit neid zu tun sondern das sind
strukturelle probleme in unserem
steuersystem die wir auch nicht nur
national lösen können sondern probieren
vernünftigen europäischen rahmen für
brauchen damit steuern denn auch da
gezahlt werden wo diese gewinne der
unternehmen erwirtschaftet werden und
daran hapert es sehr wir haben in der
pandemie noch mal vor augen geführt
bekommen das ist bei der ungleichheit in
der einkommensverteilung nicht wenn es
wird weiter auseinander gegangen ist
aber auch da ist die ungleichheit
vorhanden wesentlich größere
ungleichheiten haben wir bei der
vermögensverteilung und auch da sagen
die menschen hier geht es nicht gerecht
zu am ende müssen starke schultern
gerade in krisenzeiten dann auch mehr
zur finanzierung des gemeinwohls
beitragen und ein völlig anderes thema
ist natürlich wie gehen wir jetzt mit
den schulden um das wären bis zu 70
prozent seien des
bruttoinlandsproduktes im vergleich zu
den 60 prozent die wir vor der krise
haben da rate ich zu mehr gelassenheit
viele ökonomen haben in den letzten
monaten doch signalisiert dass die
verschuldung nicht das problem ist
sondern dass wir hier wirklich auch mit
doppeln wie schuldenbremse und schwarze
null die sie angesprochen haben
aufräumen sollten sondern wir stehen vor
einem jahrzehnt wo wir enorme
investitionen tätigen müssen da sind wir
uns ja gar nicht grundsätzlich
unterschiedlicher meinung aber die frage
ist in welche bereiche gehen die
investitionen rein und wie kriegen wir
es hin dass die öffentliche hand in die
lage versetzt wird
diese investitionen zu tätigen wir
hatten bereits im sommer 2009 10
gemeinsam mit dem institut der deutschen
wirtschaft und dem institut für
makroökonomie und konjunkturforschung
der hans-böckler-stiftung ein
gemeinsames gutachten in auftrag gegeben
die kam vor der pandemie zu dem ergebnis
dass wir ein investitionsbedarf von
round about 45 milliarden pro anno haben
über eine ganze dekade also mindestens
450 milliarden und wenn der staat seine
handlungsfähigkeit
aufrechterhalten will um in die bereiche
zu investieren die dringend notwendig
sind beispielsweise in dem bereich
regenerative energien in den bereich der
wasserstofftechnologie in den bereich
der bildung die sie auch angesprochen
haben denn wird das nicht gelingen wenn
wir an dem dogma der schwarzen null
festhalten die schuldenbremse ist eine
investitionsbremse das sehen aber nicht
nur immer mehr ökonomen so sondern wir
haben wie ich finde zu recht eine
diskussion auch innerhalb der
europäischen union und innerhalb der eu
kommission wie gehen sie mit dieser
situation um wenn wir fit for five also
auch den umweltziele die
dekarbonisierung ziele der europäischen
union wirklich realisieren wollen dann
geht das nur mit investitionen und für 1
euro öffentliche investitionen wird 1
euro 50 private investitionen zusätzlich
freigesetzt
klar ist aber auch es geht nicht nur um
öffentliche investitionen wir brauchen
in erheblichen umfang private
investitionen und das finde ich müssen
wir zu recht über beschleunigung
nachdenken über entbürokratisierung
nachdenken planungsverfahren
genehmigungsverfahren sind in den
rückschlag viel zu lang noch mal ein
bisschen bei der schwarzen null bleiben
mehr bürger das aufgeben der schwarzen
null ist das der richtige weg
also klar ist und da kann ich an herrn
hoffmann anschließen dass wir nach 180
milliarden euro neuverschuldung im
krisenjahr im darauffolgenden jahr nicht
auf null zurück springen werden das ist
unrealistisch deswegen muss die
neuverschuldung langsam ausgleichen und
wir müssen zur schwarzen null zurück
finden aber über den zeitraum wie lange
das dauert da wird noch zu reden sein
das würde man in einem jahr gehen das
wird und noch ein zwei jahren
investitionen dennoch das geht sehr wohl
wir haben schon einmal gezeigt dass es
geht nur wenn wir müssen eben in dieser
debatte auch uns ehrlich machen und
sagen dass eine ausweitung von
sozialleistungen eine ausweitung von
rentenleistungen und so weiter in diesem
umfeld dann eben nicht möglich ist weil
wir dieses geld für unsere gemeinsame
zukunft brauchen und die debatte müssen
wir ehrlich führen also wir müssen
deutschland hat die steuer von der
steuer seite her noch nie in einen namen
problem gehabt unsere steuereinnahmen
sind stetig gestiegen in den letzten
jahren allein um 300 milliarden wir
haben ein ausgabenproblem und darüber
müssen wir sprechen wir müssen darüber
sprechen wofür geben wir das geld das
wir hier erwirtschaften in zukunft aus
und da sind untereinander wir brauchen
enorme investitionen um diesen
technologiesprung zu schaffen um auch
unsere soziale gerechtigkeit zu erhalten
das tun wir aber nicht indem wir nur
über leistungsausweitung und sprechen
sondern es tun wir vor allem dadurch
indem wir darüber sprechen wo liegen die
grundlagen dass wir auch weiterhin
auskömmliche steuereinnahmen haben das
heißt dass die wirtschaft brummt und was
braucht diese wirtschaft für die zukunft
welche technologien brauchen wir und die
müssen wir vorantreiben wir haben aber
nicht nur ein technologisches problem
wir haben ja auch ein demografisches
problem wir müssen auch darüber reden
wer soll denn dieses geld in den
nächsten jahren erwirtschaften
deswegen würde ich jetzt nicht nur
darauf sie darauf schauen wollen mich
darauf fokussieren wollen wie viel
steuern werden in zukunft bezahlt die
steuereinnahmen sind bisher immer stetig
gestiegen wir müssen darauf darüber
sprechen wofür geben wie es aus und die
debatte müssen bei ehrlich und ernsthaft
aber wenn sie sagen ausgaben leicht
den richtigen punkt angesprochen wir
müssen uns verständigen über welchen
zeitraum die jetzt in der panini neu
aufgenommenen schulden getilgt werden
und da kann nicht nur auf das bundesland
nordrhein-westfalen verweisen mit einer
cdu fdp regierung die zu recht sich für
die rückzahlung der korona bedingten
neuverschuldung 50 jahre zeit nehmen
wird das halte ich für total angemessen
weil über einen solchen langen zeitraum
wie denn auch luft zum atmen haben um
nicht mit einem schnellen schuldenabbau
uns zu verirren und daneben keine
möglichkeiten haben wirklich
ambitioniert zu investieren sondern
diese schulen ähnliche situation wie
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg über lange
phasen tilgen werden das wäre
beispielsweise eine zielsetzung gemacht
da gemeinsamkeiten erreichen könnten
hätten wir schon viel gewonnen sie
sprachen davon dass man sich die
ausgabenseite genauer anschauen muss
können sie die konkrete beispiele nennen
das den letzten satz aufzugreifen über
50 jahre hört sich sinnvoll an es sind
aber anderthalb generationen und wir
müssen auch über
generationengerechtigkeit sprechen wir
müssen auch darüber sprechen was
hinterlassen wird in der nächsten
generation außer enormen aufgaben die
nicht nur technologisch sondern auch
sozialpolitisch zu bewältigen sind und
da sollten wir auf jeden fall dafür
sorgen dass es auch genügend spielräume
gibt finanzielle spielräume die zu
bewältigen und wir leben derzeit in
einem land in der die löhner höchsten
sind die energie am teuersten ist die
steuern am höchsten sind in der
eigentlich alles am höchsten und am
teuersten ist wenn man sich nur
vorstellen kann und dieses land hat
schon 100 kilometer von meinem heimatort
aus 150 kilometer eine grenze zu einem
land in dem die gewerbesteuer nur halb
so hoch sind und dem die
einkommensteuern also halb so hoch sind
die sozialabgaben nur halb so hoch sind
land der europäischen union und darüber
müssen wir reden wir müssen darüber
reden dass wir hier in einem sinnvollen
rahmen bleiben dass wir uns in europa
nach wie vor wettbewerbsfähig als
industriestandort behaupten können nur
so können wir die generation sicherheit
sichern deswegen springen wir wieder
zurück auf den punkt wenn es darum geht
die wirtschaft muss proben und wir
müssen die augen offen halten dass es
auch so kommt und mit mehrbelastungen
die uns aus sozialen versprechungen
entstehen werden wir das nicht schaffen
haben nicht erhöhen das versteht daraus
aber die ausgabenseite sei der wird sich
von selber erhöhen wenn die wirtschaft
boome wir brauchen wachstum und das
werden wir haben wenn wir die weichen
anders stellen wir müssen über die
ausgabenseite sprechen wenn man sie
darüber sprechen wofür wird dieses geld
ausgeben und deswegen ist es nicht
sinnvoll eine ausweitung von
rentenleistungen zu versprechen deswegen
ist es nicht sinnvoll eine ausweitung
von zahl von sozialleistungen zu
sprechen sondern
wir müssen uns ehrlich machen bei vielen
themen und auch mal reformen anpacken
wir werden unser rentensystem
reformieren müssen so wie es im moment
läuft kann es nicht weitergehen weil
allein unsere demographie das nicht
zulässt wir werden über mehr zuwanderung
sprechen müssen aber dann müssen wir
über qualifizierte zuwanderung sprechen
alle diese themen sind alle bekannt es
kommt jetzt nichts neues dazu an diesem
tisch aber wir müssen uns bei den themen
ehrlich machen und müssen sie ernsthaft
angehen und das sind wir auch den
nächsten generation schuldig
nächste generation heißt doch genau wenn
wir vollständig investieren und wir
haben ja heute schon
investitionsbedarf die aus der
vergangenheit
resultieren wo der öffentliche
kapitalstock regelrecht abgewirtschaftet
wurde keine vernünftigen verkehrswege
keine ausgebaute infrastruktur bei der
digitalisierung keine netze um
erneuerbare energien vom norden in den
süden zu bekommen wenn wir diese
investition nicht in den nächsten jahr
ambitioniert angehen wird das für die
jugend um ein vielfaches teurer weil
diese investitionen dann teurer werden
und die wettbewerbsfähigkeit der
unternehmen sich nur sehr langsam
vorwärts entwickeln wird also deshalb
sage ich noch mal das argument
generationengerechtigkeit um zu sagen
wir können keine neuen schulden
aufnehmen versenkt nicht weil wenn diese
investitionen nicht getätigt werden sind
die böden für die jungen generation in
zukunft deutlich höher und am besten
sehen was im bildungssystem da ich in
den letzten jahrzehnten viel zu viel
gespart worden oder viel zu wenig
investiert worden dann hätten wir
das auseinanderdriften in dem
bildungschancen
gerade eben durch das bildungssystem
befördert heute in diesem umfang nicht
um gewähren ein ganzes stück für schritt
meine position ist bei der richtung
einig auch wenn ich noch mal
herauszustreichen aber allein beim thema
infrastruktur die mittel wurden gar
nicht abgerufen deswegen vorhin mein
satz deutschland muss wieder schneller
werden wir brauchen mehr wirtschaft und
wir brauchen weniger zettel
wir sind wieder wer weil die mittel
waren da die wurden noch nicht abgerufen
das bild was an der linken regiert ist
würden für die jungen generation dieses
bild möchte ich gerne korrigieren weil
meine erfahrung auch in ungarn oder
die summen schnell
sie haben sofern unterschiedlich weil
sie sagen geld in die hand nehmen und
geld wollen sie vor allen dingen da
wollen sie die einnahmeseite ja noch
verbessern und es müsste
steuererhöhungen geben ihre meinung
damit steuersenkungen wenn wir die
probleme mit sicherheit nicht um leute
und wir sind schon der auffassung der
gew hat ja schon vor mehreren monaten
ein steuerkonzept vorgelegt wo wir
natürlich der auffassung sind dass wir
in den unteren und mittleren einkommen
durchaus entlastungen wollen wo wir aber
auch der auffassung sind dass starke
schultern mehr zur finanzierung des
gemeinwesens beitragen
und die steuern sollen dann nicht durch
die decke schießen aber eine moderate
anpassung durchaus verträglich und
gerecht wäre das gleiche
das schon hin und weil das ist ja
offensichtlich sehr kontrovers aber es
kann doch nicht sein gerade bei der
erbschaftsteuer und da geht es nicht um
das betriebsvermögen wo ich den
mittelständischen unternehmer
strangulieren will dass er sein
unternehmen nicht weiterführen kann oder
kredite aufnehmen muss wenn es vererbt
wird und ins betriebsvermögen hinein
geht also da glaube ich auch da sind wir
uns einig aber es gibt
dermaßen hohe ungerechtigkeiten die
daraus resultieren dass wir durch eine
nicht aus verfassungskonform
ausgeschüttete erbschaftsteuer wirklich
auch der gefahr widerstehen dass wir in
eine regelrechte das tier hineinlaufen
und das beweisen selbst untersuchungen
der oecd die sind unverfänglich dass das
eine gewerkschaftliche programmatik wäre
sondern es ist einfach fakt dass diese
ungerechtigkeit aufgrund der
stellschrauben die wir in unserem
steuersystem nicht nutzen und da gehört
die erbschaftsteuer zu dass wir die
einfach brachliegen das und nicht findet
das können wir uns zukünftig nicht
länger leisten ohne da bin ich bei herrn
bürger
die
bestands besteuerung in den unternehmen
so hoch zu fahren dass es die
unternehmen kennen würde da kann keiner
interesse daran haben also aber
erbschaftssteuer für würde ich gern
entschieden widersprechen zum einen
springen wir noch mal zurück zu dem
thema steuererhöhungen generell es gibt
klare studien die belegen dass durch
steuersenkungen die wirtschaft derart
besser in schwung gerät das schon wenige
jahre danach höhere steuereinnahmen der
wirtschaft würden erwirtschaftet werden
und würden als das mit steuererhöhungen
der fall gewesen wäre gibt studien die
das ganz eindeutig zeigen dass heißt
selbstverständlich gibt es auch für
steuersenkungen eine daseinsberechtigung
weil der
langfristige effekt einfach zu höheren
einnahmen führt als erhöhungen das tun
würden jetzt beim thema erbschaftssteuer
wir müssen erst mal weg von dem thema
substanzbesteuerung hier ist auch immer
mal gerne wieder eine vermögenssteuer im
gespräch da gehört auch die atomsteuer
dazu immer dann wenn sie betriebliches
vermögen
besteuern dann treffen sie die
unternehmer an ihrer empfindlichsten
stelle die nämlich ein großteil ihres
vermögens in dieser betrieb substanz
drin haben sind gebäude sind maschinen
ist know how ist gelände usw wenn sie
das besteuern dann entstehen natürlich
aus dem unternehmenswert steuerlasten
ich mache jetzt mal ein beispiel wenn
sie
kennen sie mit meister eder noch von
glück ich glaube und den darin und ärger
da irgendwo in der münchner innenstadt
sei eine tischlerwerkstatt hat ja so die
schreinerwerkstatt wenn sie die so sehen
gehen wir mal davon aus dass die
betriebsgelände von 7 bis 800
quadratmetern hat da sprechen wir heute
in der münchner innenstadt über 30
millionen euro und wenn der die
tischlerei an seinen sohn weiter vererbt
und die substanz von 30 millionen euro
muss besteuert werden über eine
erbschaftssteuer formel die verdiente in
seinem ganzen leben nicht mehr es hat
aber nur was damit zu tun dass eben
diese substanzbesteuerung
sollte man für den generationswechsel
zur besteuerung nicht heranziehen da
gibt es andere möglichkeiten die
störrischen erbschafts reformen haben
das eigentlich ganz gut abgebildet das
wurde in die nächste generation
übertragen aber diese steuerlast die
hier entsteht hat keiner der unternehmer
daheim auf dem küchentisch liegen also
davon die steuer bezahlen kann und
deswegen ist es wichtig diese
steuerreformen
weiter in die zukunft zu tragen und zu
sagen wir besteuern nicht die substanz
an sich sind steuern das unternehmen
weitergeführt wird und das wird dann in
form von boni angerechnet zum beispiel
so wie es gibt so wie es gewesen ist die
anzahl der mitarbeiter und so weiter
wenn sie an dieser schraube drehen
treiben sie die unternehmer aus dem land
und davor kann ich nur warnen das
europäische ausland hat in diesen
beziehungen haben alle bessere
bedingungen als deutschland und die
erbschaftsteuer ist in der summe aller
erwirtschafteten steuern in diesem land
nahezu bedeutungslos da reden wir über
einige milliarden aber sehr viel mehr
ist das pro jahr nicht und alle anderen
steuern die erwirtschaftet werden die
auch in diesen betrieben erwirtschaftet
werden sie sind wesentlich
bedeutungsvoller und darum sollte es
gehen es sollte darum gehen dass die
wirtschaft brummt das junge unternehmer
wieder intensiviert werden wieder ein
anreiz kriegen unternehmer zu werden
dafür müssen wir doch sorgen und nicht
darüber zu reden dass wir sagen alle
bestehenden unternehmer den bringen weil
es mal erbschaftssteuer vermögenssteuer
höhere einkommenssteuern und so weiter
sie treiben doch die unternehmen aus dem
land wir brauchen in diesem land ein
klares bekenntnis dazu dass wir noch
unternehmer wollen das unternehmen
wollen dass der industrie wollen in
diesem lande ich glaube dieses
bekenntnis kriegen sie auch von den
gewerkschaften
auch dass wir die unternehmen ich habe
das gesagt nicht strangulieren aber was
passiert wenn erben nach 45 jahren diese
unternehmen nicht mehr fortführen wollen
sie veräußert werden möglicherweise
filetiert werden beschäftigung auf dem
spiel steht menschen entlassen werden
dann muss man noch hergehen und sagen
für solche situationen brauchen wir auch
regelungen dass sie eben nicht
leistungslose erbe einfach verscherbelt
wird zu lasten der beschäftigten und das
dann auch die vermögenssteuer die
entschuldigung die erbschaftssteuer
intelligent aufgestellt wird und dass
die risiken die wir durchaus zu recht
beschreiben dass wir diese risiken
minimieren aber auf der anderen seite
geben leistungslose erbe wenn es zur
veräußerung kommt wenn es zu filetieren
kommt und da gibt es hier viele
beispiele dass wir dies dann wirklich
auch unterbinden und ein faktencheck
bezogen auf ihren nachbarland was die
sozialabgaben und die steuer betrifft
den würde ich gerne mal in frage stellen
im kern aber insofern recht dass ich
sage wir brauchen auch hier mehr
gemeinsamkeit beispielsweise bei der
gemeinsamen wenn es ums grundlage in der
unternehmensbesteuerung in der
europäischen union da wären wir schon
einen schritt weiter wir brauchen auch
dass das stopfen von
steuerschlupflöchern
innerhalb der europäischen union da
wären wir auch im ganzen schritt weiter
wenn wir dieses alles zusammen nehmen
ich glaube dann kriegen wir auch die
innovationskraft und auch die
finanzierungsmöglichkeiten geregelt die
dieses land braucht und ich sage nochmal
am besten im europäischen konzert und
nicht im nationalen alleingang
wir überspringen jetzt mal den
mindestlohn und auch die rente ist ja
dass durch
außerdem hätte weil so viel zeit haben
wir nicht mehr ich würde aber gerne auch
auf die zukunftsfragen kommen und zwar
stichwort klima
die die klimafrage ist die frage die uns
im wahlkampf beschäftigt die uns die
letzten jahre auch beschäftigt seid frei
dafür führte ruft jetzt gerade freitag
dann auch wieder zu einer großen demo
hier in berlin aber auch in anderen
städten auf würden sie sagen
konjunktureller aufholphase die wir ja
angehen müssen und klimaschutz das
schließt sich aus nein ganz im gegenteil
konjunkturelle
konjunkturelles aufholen geht auch immer
mit innovationen neuen technologien
einher und die umwelt ziele die wir uns
gesetzt haben das ist hier für unsere
industrie eine enorme herausforderung
wenn es uns gelingt in diesem land die
technologien dafür zu entwickeln dass
wir zukünftig
co2 neutral oder mit niedrigsten
emissionen unserer mobilität erhalten
können dass wir fliegen können dass
schiffe über die weltmeere fahren die
nahezu null emission haben wenn uns das
gelingt mit deutschen ideen mit
deutschen erfindungen dann haben wir
auch wieder den exportschlager der
zukunft im land ich drücke mich damals
ganz einfach aus und dann merken sie
auch wo die herausforderungen
selbstverständlich hat dieses land das
potenzial diese technologien zu
entwickeln und das sollten wir auch
vorantreiben und da sind wir uns auch
mit den gewerkschaften einig wir müssen
den fokus darauf legen top ausbildung
top technologie leistungsfähige
unternehmen förderung durch den staat in
der entwicklung dieser technologien und
dann haben wir auch in den nächsten 20
25 jahren exportstärke produkte die wir
in der ganzen welt verkaufen können und
deutschland hat das potenzial diese
probleme zu lösen und das ist auch der
grundstock dafür dass wir in zukunft
stark und erfolgreich sein können also
deswegen das widerspricht sich überhaupt
nicht ganz im gegenteil ich sehe diese
technologie wandlung die vor uns liegt
als enorme herausforderung für
zukünftige innovative produkte und für
eine exportstärke dieses landes wir
haben das potenzial die probleme zu
lösen sagt der bürger wir haben aber
auch energiepreise die einen durchaus
eine standortfrage sind und die sehr
sehr hoch sind
können wir das weiter dran sondern
überhaupt nicht die energiepreise sind
sowohl für die konsumenten begonnen
bürger mittlerweile schon an der
obergrenze und gerade die
energieintensiven
industrien
werden in ihrer wettbewerbsfähigkeit
stranguliert wenn wir da nicht
vernünftige rahmenbedingungen schaffen
für viele unternehmen sind die
energiekosten heute ein vielfaches
relevanter als beispielsweise die
lohnkosten aber die debatte will ich
jetzt nicht wieder aufmachen über das
moratorium von 40 was wir auch nicht für
zielführend teilen im kern müssen wir
uns noch mal über die gigantischen
anstrengungen im klaren werden
die uns bevorstehen mit der
dekarbonisierung unserer wirtschaft in
unserer gesellschaft ich war verbinden
wochen am start gewesen und man sich das
anschaut welche enormen mengen an
wasserstoff benötigt werden im grünen
stahl herzustellen dann brauchen wir
deutlich mehr energie als in der
vergangenheit hier haben wir in den
letzten jahren den fehler gemacht die
energie der zukunft
völlig falsch zu taxieren der
bundeswirtschaftsminister ist erst vor
wenigen wochen her gegangen und hat
diesen fehler eingesehen dem mann
festgestellt hat was wir schon seit
langem sagen die energie bedarfe sind um
ein vielfaches höher wenn wir
insbesondere auch die
energieintensive industrie in
deutschland halten wollen und da ist
viel verschlafen worden im ausbau
erneuerbarer energien in der frage der
leitungen oder auch in dem aufbau einer
tragfähigen wasserstoffwirtschaft das
wird nicht von heute auf morgen gehen da
werden wir mindestens die nächsten zehn
jahre für brauchen und es da wirklich
fit for future zu machen und das geht
nur dadurch dass alles schneller gehen
soll können sie sich nicht vorstellen
dass ich muss schneller gehen also in
aber das ist auch wirklich schneller
geht ja klar das muss schneller gehen
und die rahmenbedingungen müssten
schnell gesetzt werden ein unternehmen
was in einen neuen hochofen investieren
will der eben nicht mehr kohle befeuert
ist sondern wasserstoffbetriebenen stahl
herstellt muss eine investition in der
größenordnung von 10 milliarden euro
treffen diese investition trifft sich
das unternehmen nicht wenn endlich weiß
zu welchen energiepreisen oder zu
welchen preisen bekomme ich den
wasserstoff und was sind die
rahmenbedingungen zur herstellung von
gründen stahl weil ist nicht nur die
investitionskosten sind unter sondern
anfangen insbesondere auch die
betriebskosten sind und dass irgendwo
für ein einziges unternehmen damit ich
noch gar nicht bei der elektromobilität
wo wir enormen energiebedarf haben ob
das der ausbau der infrastruktur ist für
die elektromobilität viele dinge mehr
die bedarfe sind wirklich enorm und wir
müssen uns einfach nur noch mal auch der
dimension im klaren werden und deshalb
bin ich da durchaus für mutiges super
nicht verzagt hat ich bin auch für
beschleunigung aber wir müssen es klug
und intelligent machen und ist darf
nicht auf dem rücken der beschäftigten
ausgetragen werden wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass wir ihnen dieser
transformation auch menschen von a nach
b weiterentwickeln qualifizieren auch da
müssen wir selbst als gewerkschaften wir
werden nicht jeden arbeitsplatz in jedem
betrieb erhalten sondern diese
transformation wird mit dazu beitragen
dass menschen sich weiter entwickeln
müssen das sieht qualifiziert werden und
da bin ich durchaus denn schon auch der
meinung dass wir unsere bundesagentur
für arbeit eben nicht nur als eine
vermittlungsagentur von arbeitslosigkeit
in beschäftigung haben sondern diese
agentur in zukunft gemeinsam mit den
sozialpartnern deutlich mehr
anstrengungen unternimmt beispielsweise
wenn es um die weiterbildung geht wenn
es um das nachholen von
berufsabschlüssen geht darauf wird es
ankommen weil neben der energie ist die
qualifikation die kompetenz der
beschäftigten in deutschland das höchste
gut was wir haben und in dieses gut muss
investiert werden und zwar ambitioniert
zwei fragen gleich einmal nach dem start
nach der staatlichen beteiligung
neben neue technologien
zu fördern und
voranzubringen brauchen wir die und
können wir die geschwindigkeit so wie
sie jetzt ist beibehalten oder wie
können wir sie beschleunigen nun an dem
punkt sind wir uns einig es muss
zumindest mit den technologien die wir
jetzt vorantreiben wollen schneller
gehen als in der vergangenheit zum thema
energie
da haben wir viel dazugelernt aber auch
hier muss es einfach schneller gehen und
da ist auch die debatte darüber zu
führen was wir in der vergangenheit
gekonnt haben sind wir zu schnell aus
der atomenergie ausgestiegen haben wir
es falsch angegangen erst die
atomkraftwerke abzuschalten dann die
kohlekraftwerke hätten was anderswo
machen müssen da sind wir heute schon
viel weiter aber hoffentlich kommen wir
in dieser debatte dann auch zu der
erkenntnis dass man zum beispiel auch
mal die atomkraftwerke länger laufen
lässt bevor wir dann ich sage mal im
ausland wenn wir spitzen brauchen
ausländischen atomstrom zu kaufen da
hätten wir auch nicht viel bekommt also
diese debatten sollten wir glaube ich
offen führen und ehrlich führen wir
haben vorhin im gespräch schon mehrfach
an punkten habe ich herausgestrichen wir
müssen uns ehrlich machen wir müssen
ehrlich darüber reden wo wir jetzt den
roten faden aufnehmen und sagen diesen
weg gehen wir jetzt gemeinsam in die
zukunft staatliche unterstützung bei
neuen technologien auch dass du
vielleicht auch sagen müssen so schnell
wie die ziele jetzt angegangen werden
schafft man es dann doch auch die
diskussion müssen wir führen ein
gegenseitiger überbietungswettbewerb
waren wir jetzt keine verbrenner mehr
zulassen die zahl sind dann
untersagt mal 2030 da ist auch nicht
viel gekonnt wir werden an vielen dingen
erleben müssen das eben auch die
verbraucher hier eine ganze menge
mitzureden haben wie lange sie ihre
fahrzeuge noch fahren wie lange das noch
alles dauern wird was wir auch technisch
leisten können es geht auch um die
infrastruktur es geht um ein grid also
um ein verteilungsnetz für energie dass
wir auch alle unsere elektroautos
aufladen können da sind viele fragen
noch nicht beantwortet auch in den
innenstädten vor allem nicht beantwortet
aber thema staatliche förderung beim
entwickeln neuer technologien ja das
macht auf jeden fall sinn und das wird
auch gebraucht werden und das sollte nur
auf jeden fall auch tun denn der ganze
mittelstand wird aus diesen
fördermitteln auf jeden fall ich sag mal
was sinnvolles machen und da werden auch
gute ergebnisse dabei herauskommen
dieses vertrauen sollte da sein und
staatliche förderung ja thema
fortbildung auch ganz wichtig da müssen
wir gemeinsam viel des landes
mit unserem sozialpartner zusammen
müssen wir den richtigen weg finden ich
glaube nicht dass es in den händen der
bundesagentur in den händen der
bundesagentur so gut aufgehoben ist
sondern die beträgt die weiterbildung
muss auf betrieblicher basis stattfinden
das heißt wir müssen ja auch das
ausbilden was die betriebe brauchen und
das können natürlich immer mit den
betrieben zusammen am besten und wie
dann die richtige struktur dafür
aussieht darüber wird zu reden sein aber
ein weiterbildungs monster in form der
bundesagentur für arbeit alleinig
hinzustellen und zu sagen jeder der sich
beruflich weiterbilden will wird das
dort tun das halte ich für falsch das
muss gemeinsam mit den betrieben
gemeinsam mit den sozialpartnern
geschehen auch da wird staatliche hilfe
notwendig sein das können wir auch nicht
alles alleine aufbringen und dies aber
ein thema das wir angehen müssen weil
wir auch alle länger arbeiten wollen und
länger arbeiten müssen wir sind quasi am
schluss der sendung hofft man dass wegen
einer schlussfrage welche
regierungskonstellation wir sind ja nun
mal im wahlkampf noch würden sie denn
zutrauen dass es die zukunftsfragen am
besten anpackt dann wenn ich mir die
wahlprogramme anschaue dann wundert es
nicht dass das was wir vorgeschlagen
haben wir hohe schnittmengen haben mit
der spd ich sehe aber durchaus auch
einige bereiche wo wir schnittmengen
haben mit der fdp als auch mit den
grünen und dann muss man mal schauen was
der wähler die wählerin am sonntag
entscheidet und ich kann alle
demokratischen parteien nur ermuntern
zügig zu koalitionsverhandlungen zu
kommen nicht ewig zu sondieren aber für
heute würde ich mir erst mal wünschen
auch eine botschaft an die bürgerinnen
und bürger machen sie gebrauch von ihrem
wahlrecht wir brauchen eine hohe
wahlbeteiligung für die demokratischen
parteien in diesem lande feinde der
demokratie können wir im deutschen
bundestag nicht gebrauchen das sind die
spd erwähnt haben liegt auch nicht
zuletzt daran dass die spd mitglied sind
ist weil ich der ich habe auch wenn ich
hier auch der grüne gesagt er kenne auch
ich haben gemeinsam artikel welche eine
lasche zur mitbestimmung geschrieben
also auch da haben wir durchaus
berührungspunkte
das werden am 26
es werden am 26 die wähler entscheiden
und deswegen kann ich es nur aufgreifen
was er hofft man gesagt bitte unbedingt
alle zahlreich an die urnen gehen und
unbedingt wählen denn es geht um was es
geht um die zukunft dieses landes und
wir haben hier gemeinsam jetzt in dieser
sendung formuliert wer das rennen macht
können wir auch nicht sagen wir können
aber sagen was wir von der zukünftigen
bundesregierung erwarten und das haben
wir getan wir brauchen aufbruchstimmung
wir brauchen mehr ludwig erhard
deutschland muss einfacher werden und
wir müssen einfach wieder schneller und
dynamischer werden das würde ich mir
wünschen dass das auch mit dem
wahlergebnis richtig in schwung kommt
ich bedanke mich sehr herzlich für diese
sehr angeregte diskussion und ich
bedanke mich bei ihnen sehr herzlich
fürs zuschauen das war unter dem linken
das letzte vor der bundestagswahl gehen
sie am sonntag wählen den aufruf haben
sie gehört und was sich wirtschaft und
arbeitnehmer oder gewerkschaften
vorstellen was alles an zu packen ist
das konnten sie hier verfolgen einen
schönen abend noch mal fällig
[Musik]